if you were a one of the 225 million
people in the United States who received
the text message yesterday called a
presidential alert you might be
wondering what on earth it was and what
it has to do with the president and
particularly with President Donald Trump
I was here in Las Vegas Nevada in a lyft
ride at the time between venues and
everyone in the car including the
drivers phone went off with an alarm and
a text message like thing which was
actually not not exactly a text message
which said emergency alert message
presidential alert October 3rd 2018
11:18 a.m. that was - 2:18 p.m. on the
East Coast I'm in Pacific time this is a
test of the national wireless emergency
alert system no action is needed
expiration unspecified expiry time this
is a system that has actually been
around for a while
and it's connected to that system that's
usually reserved for things like missing
children Amber Alerts or like flash
flood warnings or other weather warnings
or some kind of serious national
emergency so I understand when you see
it's a presidential alert you start to
wonder what's going on and the immediate
fear from people on social media was oh
no is this going to be a way for Donald
Trump to basically text all Americans or
all or most of the Americans that have a
phone does this mean that if Robert
Muller comes out with serious findings
about Trump that Trump will immediately
text all Americans and tell them to loot
or to strike or to do whatever in
protest of Robert Muller and the answer
is it doesn't it doesn't seem like it
although I understand why given the
authoritarian slide of our current
president one would see a presidential
alert text message come through and
think that this is going to be the way
that Trump speaks directly to everybody
without them being able to opt out it
doesn't seem like it FEMA is saying that
this is just a test of a more modernized
EAS system
or EAS s stands for system which has
already allowed for decades for the
President to decide to broadcast
something on all television and radio
stations in the country and they're
adding mobile phones since increasingly
mobile phones are the way that people
get news and are in communication with
people right after the smart phone
message went out yesterday to 225
million people TV and radio stations
also received kind of like an equivalent
test message so the long and short of it
is as far as we're being told this isn't
something that Donald Trump or another
president could use to just send a text
message to every American but that it's
now part of the FEMA program that can be
used for emergencies I think that it
might have been a mistake to call it a
presidential alert because we know how
much Trump would love to be able to text
every American when you imagine him at
3:00 a.m. sitting wherever it is that he
sits and tweeting stuff out to his
however many million followers there's
no question that he would love to also
be able to send those messages directly
to everybody with a mobile phone but
there is actually a law in place that
would prevent him from abusing the
system it's called the integrated public
alert and warning system Modernization
Act of 2015 and what that law says is
that the system can only be used to warn
people about potential disasters and
Donald Trump would be breaking the law
if he were to misuse that system but a
sitting president can't be indicted
right we've been hearing that for months
so would there really be any
consequences to Trump for misusing that
system I don't really think so and the
House and Senate are definitely not
going to impeach a president for
misusing the emergency alert system and
the the real problem many people are
having is that you can't opt out and I
can imagine at least some scenarios
where this could backfire
imagine for a second that you are in a
school and there is an active shooter
terrorism scenario your phone
silenced your sheltered in place the
terrorists are walking around looking
for people to shoot you would have been
able to stay hidden until that
presidential alert goes off on your
phone you can't silence it
you can't opt out now the terrorists
hear your phone find you and shoot you
dead I don't know I mean that's just one
scenario I can imagine but that's
actually the question I want to hear
from you about should there be some
opt-out method is it a problem that no
matter what phone settings you put on
other than I guess if you do airplane
mode it's possible that the text that
the emergency message wouldn't get to
you should there be some opt-out for
such a system or or not and and are you
pleased with the way that the test went
let me know Twitter at D Pakman
Instagram at David Pakman facebook.com
slash David Pakman show I want to hear
from you about it today's program is
supported in part by title the music
streaming app that actually fosters the
relationship between artists and their
fans and values diversity in music you
can get unlimited music and video
completely add free untitled play your
clay a favorite classics or discover new
artists they also have a very important
benefit concert coming up on October
23rd this is their fourth annual benefit
concert called title x Brooklyn and the
goal of this concert is to support
criminal justice reform something we
talked about on the David Pakman show
all the time you may know that in our
criminal justice system more than
two-thirds of prisoners who are serving
life without parole for nonviolent
offenses are African Americans one in
every fifteen males is incarcerated the
rate for white males is one in 106 this
means that one in three African American
men can expect to go to prison in their
lifetime and the title X Brooklyn show
will send all net proceeds to charity
organizations that want to reform these
numbers including the Innocence Project
which we've spoken about as well as the
equal justice initiative reform cut
fifty past concerts of featured artists
like Stevie
wonder jay-z Jennifer Lopez Nicki Minaj
you can check out the free live stream
of Title X Brooklyn on October 23rd tune
in donate at title comm slash Brooklyn
that's tid al.com forward slash Brooklyn